en outre
c'est l'histoire de florent un jeune
dépressif qui va consulter son
psychothérapeute sans savoir que tous
deux vont explorer et revivent de
nombreuses aventures à travers les
époques ce spectacle a été écrit à
partir de transcription de vraies
régressions ce qu'on appelle des
régressions dans des vies antérieures
donc une technique de psychothérapie qui
va chercher dans l'autre donc passé du
patient dans l'enfer en fait dans la
mémoire du patient c'est ses traumas de
façon à les rendre la conscience et de
résoudre ses problèmes psychologiques
l'odyssée du temps de la grande scène du
chéné rocancourt c'est une vingtaine de
comédiens cascadeurs musiciens et même
deux chevaux ça va au-delà de ce que je
pensais
un spectacle très spectaculaire c'est
sans jeu de mots mêmes essais
époustouflants c'est une série de ce
qu'on appelle en
spectacle aussi ainsi une série de tours
de force donc chaque chaque tableau
chaque époque était est un tour de force
je pense que les gens vont bien rigoler
et s'attacher à chaque personnage chaque
personnage est attachant et chaque
univers
et unique en plus d'être tenues et
maquillage le choix de faire jouer la
musique directement sur scène pour plus
d'immersion c'est ramène carrément les
époques parce que le son des instruments
nous transporte tout de suite dans la
bonne époque est comme ça ça simplifie
aussi pour le spectateur la lecture des
tableaux un spectacle qui voit grand et
qui n'a pas fait peur à la grande scène
déjà prêtes à l'accueillir c'est un
spectacle qui vient au bout de dix ans
d'histoire en fait qu'on peut se
permettre de le faire et les contraintes
c'est bien sûr des contraintes
techniques avec des choses particulières
parce qu'il ya des cascades il ya quand
même des armes à feu il ya des
projections vidéo projection rétro
rétroprojection assez particulière et
puis à beaucoup de monde sur scène donc
évidemment ça demande du monde et ça
demande beaucoup d'expertisé beaucoup de
répétitions 800 personnes sont attendues
pour venir voir les deux représentations
samedi 13 novembre à 20h30 et dimanche
14 à 15 heures